[Musik]
meine damen und herren es hat gerade
angefangen zu regnen
draußen wow wetter ist berechnete
eingeblendet meine damen und herren wir
spielen heute mal wieder vor
ich liege auf einem teppich ich habe auf
youtube ein video im text namens des
ford night club will have one million
views 180 halt okay was ist das komisch
katyn und dieses video hat tatsächlich
elf millionen aufrufe nach zwei wochen
bekommen von daher hab ich mir gedacht
hey warum schwierig weil wir vor neid
die kamera steht übrigens gerade hier
auf meinem sport und ich werde jetzt mit
euch fordert spielen freunde und juli
denkst du ich wir sehen uns jetzt in
fordert wieder eigentlich schon ein
bisschen strange dass man einfach mit
dem bus dann und einem luftballon da ich
frage mich ja gar nichts mehr was ist
das denn
deswegen grafikfehler das ist hallo
wow
dieses fordert video wird eine million
aufrufe bekommen lukas strich habe ein
bisschen mehr an hier
neue runde neues glück freunde
ach du scheiße hätten schlauchboot
hahaha opfer kann die zone nicht ein
verdammtes mal auf meiner seite sein
logo 100 das schild nicht so dass ich
das bräuchte aber tut schon ganz gut ich
brauche erstmal noch ein bisschen holz
ich glaube das sollte das mal reichen
was ist das denn
also früher war das hier tomato town
jetzt ist das irgendwie tomato tempel
und trommel gewährt ach du scheiße das
ist einfach so ein feuer das fordert
klipp 0 gärten one million views
ich habe gar keine zeit mehr um einen
kurzen bush ihr ahnt es nicht leute ich
laufe jetzt hier einfach als bush rum
wie geil
das war die kürzeste zeit die je jemand
in fordert als bush verbracht hat voll
krass eigentlich dass es hinter dieser
zone einfach immer regnet auf ein meldet
ist hier natürlich mal wieder komplett
am arsch ich füge mit anderen maus oder
weißt du meine gewinner aus ich kann den
sieg in dieser runde schon förmlich
riechen
leute ich glaube ich achte als wieder
dieser bastard ich weiß nicht was der
macht aber irgendwie bin ich wenn ich
darüber nach hallo ich bin der
schornsteinfeger wie wenn man in der
nähe von diesem komischen würfel händen
stirbt man einfach so hey warum die
nicht die zone eigentlich komplett
verarschen ich bin ein echter weste
fordert spieler wo sind denn die gegner
das war ehrlich auch du scheiße das ist
ein gegner aad10 ist gar nicht mal so
schlecht isa fordert clips wird eine
million aufrufe genug hört muss noch
irgend etwas krasses machen hier dachte
ich halt dass sich einfach mal abwarten
bis irgendjemand enthüllte towers in
meinem falle läuft
alter schwede ich laufe seit vier
minuten rum durch diesen raum habe ihn
komplett leer gemacht habe hier eine
zahl und warte darauf dass hier jemand
durch kommt einfach verdammt noch mal
keiner dann mache ich das jetzt auf
meine eigene art und weise hier ach du
scheiße das geht mülltonne was den
gottes namen ist denn ein taschen riss
und den setzt sich ein wenn ich irgendwo
ohne gefahr einem keller bin nur ein
armer du scheiße von wovon wovon wo
eigentlich wenig zu achten und die rad
sich mies gelaufen
das beschreibt mein leben eigentlich
relativ gut zeigt er jetzt nur ein life
verlieren fordert freuen und zwar hinter
dieser wand hier wenn ihr die hier
abbaut seht ihr schon verbirgt sich eine
so war es denn ist das hier
ach du scheiße kann ich da von wand zu
wand springen
hier kann ich übrigens immer wieder zu
diesem komischen tomate tempel dahin
nice alter diese teile sind richtig
hilft jeder ganz einfach so machen und
jetzt ist da hinten eine festung ich
verstehe nicht warum wir diesen tomate
tempel nie so viele leute sind weil hier
sind so heftige sache nachttisch als
broadliner ach das war meine festung ich
spaß hier gibts echt heftige sachen und
noch heftige leute wie mich achten mal
wieder ein bisschen auf dem feuer tanzen
hier ist dass da eigentlich für ein
gesicht drauf denn der julis gesicht
drauf wer dann wäre es ein hexenkessel
juli macht jetzt übrigens auf blockt
jemand ganz kurzer ausschnitt ist jetzt
wieder vergangen ich habe karten saft
getrunken
[Musik]
hiermit könnte man news content
eigentlich recht gut beschreiben
haha nein lauf schneller diese zone ist
einfach so ein kleines stück vor mir das
ist nicht wahr dass sich sein was was
euer scheiß erst nach hast du verloren
was guckst du dir jetzt angelaufen
katzenbaby
[Musik]
ebenfalls zum breakdance battle will ich
meld dich unter der e mail adresse
wir sehen uns dann ach du scheiße kuppel
chinesische essen bestellen ist richtig
nah ist man weiß nicht ob lecker
schmeckt oder ob man die nächsten drei
tage durch verrottung kurzen muss ich
werde die nächsten drei tage durchfall
haben ich weiß nicht was auch der kamera
krass rüberkommt aber ich halte euch mal
ans fenster ist als die übelste monsun
schaut euch mal die regentropfen da an
ich meine die klasse setzten die langen
auch noch kaputt das neuerdings
architekt ja die das schon richtig gut
aus kleine schwarze du machst du nach
das ist der grundriss eine ewigkeit
später einige stunden hewlett wirklich
hier gesessen und hat einfach meine
wohnung nachgebaut
ich mache meine tipps wie sie mir die
zeit
ok
und die werden danke
wenn ich manchmal schicken ich wollte
allerdings noch auf einen kommentar
eingehen der unter den gestrigen blog
geschrieben wurde wie du dich einfach an
stellt wieso sollten nudeln für 39 cent
schlechter sein als nudeln für zwei euro
kann es sein dass man einfach nicht
kochen kann ja eigentlich kann ich nicht
kochen und deswegen habe ich das gesagt
nein natürlich nicht freunde am viele
reiche leute haben auch um die
kommentare geschrieben ich würde alle
hingegen die voll schlecht machen wo
konntet ihr das bitte raus hören ist ist
jedem selbst überlassen wolle seine
lebensmittel einkauft erstmal kurz der
hintergrund warum ich jetzt drauf gerade
eingehe im gestrigen blog hatte ich
versucht 24 stunden von nur einem euro
zu leben und bin deswegen den aldi
gegangen weil weit umgestaltete der
günstigste supermarkt hier in der nähe
ist und als ich dann im aldi war bin ich
erstmal nicht richtig klargekommen ich
wusste nicht ob überhaupt nudeln haben
wo die überhaupt noch drin haben weil
real toren hinter einem regal wo einfach
gartengeräte waren und nur weil ich beim
essen der nudel nachher gesagt habe ich
diese neuen resistenten mönstetten
genauso wie die zwei euro nudel rest
doch nicht dass ich jetzt irgendwie
sagen dass das schlechtere nudeln sind
oder so das ist doch voll positiv den
nudeln gegenüber allerdings am trotzdem
leider voll viele leute in die
kommentare geschrieben
nur weil du hier youtube man die masse
und alles mögliche musst du nicht leute
schlecht machen die kleinen war wie so
legt die mir solche wörter in den mund
ich bin nicht der meinung dass alle die
irgendwie schlechter ist als supermarkt
xyz oder so die sache dass nur wenn man
in köln hat man halt alle 20 metern
ribéry bekommt aus köln und man das ist
einfach so keine ahnung das ist halt der
nächste supermarkt an die tatsache dass
sich in der innenstadt wohne und der
nächste aldi zwei kilometer entfernt ist
zeigt das glaube ich relativ stark wo
man dann er hingeht also sorry an alle
hier haben beleidigt gefühlt tun das
wird das in deutsch sowie auf jeden fall
das tut mir leid das sollte nicht so
rüberkam
ich will überhaupt keinen eingehen der
war aldi irgendwie seine lebensmittel
kauft meine mom kauft auch bei aldi die
meisten produkte ein und ich meine du
kaufst du so ein
ich glaube sie meint - um die eheleute
spiel ist jetzt gar nicht so komisch
ernst machen die alles ich habe noch
einige kommentare in die richtung
gesehen und wollte einfach wissen dass
ich kein mensch bin der jetzt irgendwie
sagt ja eh du bist ein schlechterer
mensch wandel für 39 cent ist nicht mein
weg ins nicht früher die zeiten wo man
mit 35 minuten terrinen irgendwie in die
schule gegangen ist an der stelle würde
den heutigen doch jetzt allerdings auch
werden weil der damen und herren wenn es
euch gefallen hat das doch gerne mal
einen daumen nach oben
darum nach oben ist die richtige
richtung schreibt in die kommentare wenn
ihr auch manchmal ein buchgeschenk
[Musik]